he has put up in the last four
years fire back down Lea zones
we'll see a plays that back
around back in by Simone
benw on the boards a turnover forced by knce
there's SP with another good chance Sweden if
he doesn't make the Red Wings this year he'll
playing Grand Rapids in the American Hockey
League in comes McCain drops it off for homberg
homberg winds in rolls up towards the goal lion
save rebound loosen but can't couldn't reach it
running around in their own end and battles lost
on the wrong side of pox and if Toronto plays hard
they'll get these kind of chances I guess that's
the slash pivots back in the corter moves out and
shoots L makes the Stop and Danielson back with it
it's picked off by Mar mov around gois bear marter
slides that back neander it's William neander come
[Music]
on he is good on the wing Mitch Marner rarely
these guys get out in this situation Marner
is using with Matthew but Matthew's
in the Box the delay dages everyone
way too low so dip their toes in
the free agent pool last couple of
Summers off for a cough and and others
good chance walking for the puck by TJ
Brody back at the point go bear shoot scores
that was tipped in the high slot might have
been Danielson who got a piece of that and it's
a 1-1 time I think what they've seen out of him
is Char's in good position right here no one
identifies Danielson bro there but doesn't quite
get the about to take to see how high that high
stick was danielson's floating across the hash
marks and it's hard to get that far away from
the net you see Bry knows where he wants him
now that's going to be good Roy knows he's his
guy but it's hard to get to a stick that far I
got no problem that being interference though if
you're going to call it that way every game all
game all for it so the trick of the power play
the last one lasted 5 seconds in shoot scores
and that one lasted six and they scored on it w
what a rip see 67 games his first NHL season and
the way Toronto Works their rotation they give up
that shot the cave was supposed to block the far
side of the net and if you beat the goer that's
supposed to be more in the goer now you'd like to
push him further wide he's quite narrow almost on
the faceof circle and that's because the face off
was on the other side to start the play but
got to 9 in Detroit here and leardi picks it
free hall now a centering pass for Lombardi he's
got Samson off down tried to tuck it in he Dives
across KN L back across to Taris drop that back
to Ry able to hold the line 15 seconds to go on
the first penalty neander got the slide that
across picked off by Daniels he sends it down
the ey 19 going on 29 the way he's playing Marner
takes that long pass from Riley time winding down
to the first penalty tarz Marner Matthews scores
Austin Matthews power play goal and the game is
tied at [Applause] two time and space where it's
on the clock who's coming out of the box Detroit
gets caught getting flooded on one side as though
it might be a five on four it's not a five on four
yet benro stick in the air crosschecking Elan on
the back and arner slipped it right through for a
one-time so Austin Matthews drops to a need to get
a pass lion and that came just after the five on
three and provides similar kind of results as
the other two pairs that are locked in gam will
start this second period five on five tied to
two as Morgan riy goes ahead to Mitch Marner
marer throws out around fer tied up there by
verzi Veri the former red trying to dig that
great BR back for Riley and the Matthew with the
shot L at the same rebound loose hard reaching for
Toronto generates more per home game than Detroit
does right now generates more for home game than
anyone does actually in comes n with a short
headed chance St by Li a great stretch in March
and April and bosi was hurt to start that stretch
but then bosi was healthy was backing up they just
said no we're going with a guy who's playing
better that was Alex lion oh bble by the for
scor maic with the giveaway and the former red
out of bzi makes a pay to make it 3-2 Toronto
bzi jumps on a loose par that's a tough turnover
he bring it back into the Zone Marco Casper but
it's just a fan back at pass he heals it so many
times when a turnover like that occurs the gender
never quite get settled you see Lions coming
out from that time a Paar lays it back across
for berren to the PA back for Danielson BS it
and shoot trying to find the Stick of valeno
that went just wide pass picked off by Riley up
ahead to Matthews with Marner in comes Matthews
he's got lion down on try and lion gets the left
pad down make the stop rather have someone else
do the penalty killing and get him more five on
five ice where he's significantly better than most
on his team Rosie chips that back down the draw
Zone samsonov plays it back around loose P score
a gravy bounce to Dominic shy he ties
the game with 134 to go in the second
period not wanted to be clean well this
is not that couple shoulder checks and
he just gets beat to the spot by mileno
good hands M's got to be yelling at him
he thinks he has time here but mileno
jumps the route and picks it off shine
is there for an easy one quick tap in empty
the Michigan guy grew up in Detroit played a
northern I look at and say God he's played a
long time look at all the scars on his face
I was think of the same thing just fresh face
not a mark on him and now he's he did not get
those scars shaving AR loosen the corner with it
plays that back around for toara to Riley back
for neander bring wide pass toar in shoots lion
backing up made the save he was half in the net
when he made that stop he hadn't gotten across
got square at all partner with it walks in throws
it back in for forne and a point blank save by
Li to pick there by Edinson time wind down here
in the period fer Sten by tarz centers it knocked
down by Hall out by jordano final second shoot by
knock that away this game will go to overtime
tied at three after a scoreless third period
you were able to win this face
off dson wins the
draw K got him he on for now danelson
sliding in D in shoots it goes
off away comes Austin Matthews in across the
line turns valeno spins that back to nander
neander in shoots William neander overtime
winner and throw takes it [Applause] 43
opens and closes the scoring put him on the
wing he'll score four on four and three on
three William neander who had himself a really
good night penalty killing five on five special
teams you name it picks up his second of the
night in overtime to end the game and they
finally get the puck back Austin Matthews dri
everyone really deep allows willander attack
no pressure drag pull this one catches the Stick
of sherat goes opposite side of the net but shat
can't close on him he's just too deep you got
to back up because of the speed and skill of
Matthews and neander and a good break results
in the end of the game Meander with his second
likely his last game of the preseason he'll head
to the season ER feeling good about his offense